we're playing apex legends mobile and
every time one of the boys gets a kill
they win 5 000 for their friend but only
the person with the most kills at the
end of the video gets the money start
the timer the challenge has officially
begun here we go
come on chandler i need you to move me
out my mom's house wait there's people
landing with us we're gonna screw their
day up because we're playing for money
get these over here get these
look at this look at this god tier loot
right here you're welcome
oh there's people in front of me
i need those kills
get finished where are the people
oh my gosh there's like 18 people
that's two kills
there's people in front of me
there's a lot of people around us right
now there's a guy over here
dude i'm eating jimmy
there we go chris is up to three i'm
nervous i only have two kills carlos
zero thanks for asking is there a reason
you hate terry contact
um
uh what do you say oh carl has one kill
you know if you do really well that
means zay can't move out of his mom's
house well i'm basically about to move
in with his mom carl's about to wipe a
whole squad
[Music]
oh my god when did you get six kills i'm
a gamer i'm a gamer that's what i was
meant to do
guys carl has seven kills so you're
telling me carl likes streak more than
you like martin i just haven't seen a
single person there's a real player over
here and he's good he just beat me
i'm out of ammo everywhere chris swap
out i guess don't worry
eight minutes has gone by boys i might
just put down my ipad to give them a
chance
50 000 for tariq
oh my god
please somebody stop carl okay
wait no how's carl getting so many kills
like everybody is actually good that i'm
facing
no the car will go down this could be my
chance carl went down oh my god i need
to find people carl aren't you glad apex
legend sponsored this video apex legends
mobile is the best apple that's ever
been on the app store apex legends
mobile is a battle royale where you go
up against 60 other players and last
team standing wins apex also just
launched the cold snap event which adds
unique weather to the map and introduces
loba the character with abilities that
helps you find the best loot in the map
the event also has challenges each week
that if you do will unlock cool cosmetic
items click the link in the description
to download for free today carl you you
got down yeah but i'm still surviving
i'm currently on 60k feeling good
feeling great oh how about you share
some kills why would i share kills when
i'm trying to win
guys there's people on me
dude it's so hard to use this gun 41
minutes to change my life i'm trying so
hard has anyone seen anyone yes they're
all around me okay
don't get god get them
what is this going
you got him got him got him right chris
is following you
let's go
oh chris took it okay i've been over
here killing this whole team get out of
here
oh there's so many people over here
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh knock down
oh there is someone here finally
for this game you made me 20k closer 60k
looking at 80k i know i gotta find
people you gotta find some people
contact we got 29 people left oh 27 now
that's it that's you that's you let's go
let's go let's go let's go 35 minutes
raining how are you doing chris i just
love a couple of extra kills
you're about five kills behind carl how
are you feeling over here i i think i
can catch up tariq do you know how much
money you've won around eighty ninety
thousand ninety thousand dollars but if
chandler comes back and passes carl you
get nothing let's just follow call and
then we can take all the kills from him
children why are you on top of me you're
not getting a kill i'm gonna separate
separate from them
notifications that means there's people
right here
oh chandler got there first bros shoots
yes holy crap chandler's only four kills
behind carl now
you got a kill
oh there's one there's one there's one
so it's frustrating because you have to
shoot an aim at the same time
oh i'm down
another one i'm just going to move to
the next one they're not going to revive
me to be honest
all the boys are breaking off
30 minutes remaining the challenge is
halfway done drinks won 90 grand they
won 85 grand and martin's on 35 grand
and remember only the person who has the
most kills at the end of the video
actually wins the money i'm barely in
the leaders 30 minutes left carl let's
get this done i know everyone's counting
you out chris but if you wipe two squads
you're right back with hey if only i
could aim well
get him get him give him get him
all right he's knocked
just over 20 minutes remaining and
carl's lead is dwindling girl undwindle
the lead i'm on dwindling it
just died again
it is now tied between chandler and carl
either tariq or jose is going to get
rich let's find out we got this
not anymore chandler just took the lead
for the first time in the video
[Music]
oh i need ammo i need that one
[Music]
let's go
they're catching up 10 minutes remaining
carl has 25 kills chandler has 26. chris
you are in dead last i've ran across the
entire map didn't see anybody so now i'm
running back let's do this let's just
get this let's get this lead back
did he take your kill
he took your kill
yes let's go let's go let's go six
minutes remaining they have 27 kills
they have 26. this is neck and neck i
can do this come on i just need to find
somebody oh my god don't do it
there's a ton of tingles right here i
just have to not die
yes let's go
yes you got it guys carl just knocked
two one oh my god come on bro
that's three yes let's freaking go
carl's now in the lead five minutes
remaining
knocked
out knocked carl you got this keep this
lead baby oh give me somebody this is
crazy
let's go let's go let's go two kill
difference two minutes and 19 seconds
remaining give me people and he's about
to get thirty two right there try to
focus carl
eliminated 33. let's go yeah
we have 29 bro i haven't seen someone
for five minutes
are you yes
all right hands up hands off take your
hands off chandler ended with 29 kills
chris ended with 16 kills and carl ended
with 34k
what's 34 times 5 000. here's the money
you just won congratulations everyone if
you haven't already click the
description download and pick